saving lives and reuniting people in
just
one vial of indistinguishable clear
liquid
but the real magic has been the scale
the industrial production the shared
effort
all culminating in small very private
intimate moments in halls and surgeries
around britain
the beginning of the end of the pandemic
comes so simply
and quickly i'm feeling very excited
very privileged
and really pleased to have had it it's
very easy
the the process the volunteers
everyone's
in their place and helping us no wonder
the prime minister wants to be seen here
at a gp-led vaccine center in kent
where they tell me they expect soon
they'll be weeks ahead of schedule
even as boris johnson tries to tell the
nation that there are likely to be lots
of restrictions that stay for now
no vaccination program is 100 effective
and so when you have a large volume of
circulation we've got
a lot of disease inevitably the
vulnerable
will will suffer so that's why we wanted
to drive it right down
keep it right down it's in vaccination
rooms like this one that britain is
getting its passport out
of coronavirus but what will the new
normal look like boris johnson told us
today that no vaccination process
is a hundred percent successful one of
the biggest arguments therefore inside
whitehall right now is whether or not to
keep social distancing will the one
meter plus rule survive
if it does that could mean fewer
customers in pubs and bars and
restaurants
some of them going under but some
government scientists
think it should stay the vaccine program
a success but not the time to abandon
all restrictions
this is an unprecedented national
achievement
but it's no moment to relax
and in fact it's the moment to
accelerate because
the threat from this virus remains very
real
we want this lockdown
to be the last and we want
progress to be cautious
but also irreversible prime minister you
warned this morning that no
vaccination program is a hundred percent
effective professor chris witte
what are the implications of this for
protecting public health do you think
some social distancing measures will now
become
permanent the risk will gradually go
down so it won't suddenly move from a
uh you having to do everything to
nothing whether it'll get it down to the
point where
it's zero for all time or whether it'll
take it down to a very low level where
there's some residual there's scores or
a level
where very occasionally you have to do
things in a particular point in the
season for example
i think it's too early to say the army's
still assisting as the vaccine rollout
pace now doubles
jabbing for victory sam coates sky news